le nouveau ministre de la santé madame
simone veil a l'intention de s'informer
concrètement des problèmes sociaux posés
à son ministère pour une de ses
premières sorties elle a choisi de se
rendre à suresnes dans un foyer de
jeunes travailleurs et dans un foyer de
personnes âgées
je crois qu'il était bon qu'à ministre
la santé montre qu'il était bien sûr
soucieux de la santé de tous les
français s'intéressent aux hôpitaux mais
qu'il y avait aussi dans son département
ministériel tout le secteur social et
dans ce secteur social il ya en tout
premier lieu naturellement les jeunes
fument pas et les vieillards puisque là
que la direction des aides sociales se
préoccupe de toute l'assistance à
apporter à ces différentes catégories de
personnes pour ce qui le concerne les
jeunes
j'ai visité un foyer de jeunes
travailleurs parce que c'est une
catégorie de jeunes qui a
particulièrement besoin qu'on s'occupe
d'elle il s'agit de deux jeunes qui
souvent ont rompu leurs liens avec leurs
familles qui sont trouvés en difficulté
ou qui ne gagnent pas encore
suffisamment comprend se débrouiller
seul dans la vie et c'est vraiment je
crois le rôle de notre société de les
aider de paul en charge pour qu'ensuite
puisse se développer dans les meilleures
conditions les aider pour commencer dès
qu'ils seront mariés poseront leur
proposait le foyer des personnes âgées
ensuite reçu le 8 de madame veil
accompagné de monsieur le noir le
secrétaire d'état à l'action sociale
alors ici au contraire c'est l'autre
côté c'est la fin de la vie qu'on essaye
d'améliorer je trouve que ce foyer il
faudrait que j'en ai beaucoup
les citadins c'est très intéressant de
le visiter pour voir justement ce qu'on
pouvait faire pour que les personnes qui
toute la vie on travaille et qui ont été
nos ennemis
le puits se trouvait vieillesse heureuse
dans les meilleures conditions
exotisme de faire un effort dans ce sens
là oui sûrement je crois qu'il ya
vraiment
beaucoup à faire et que les passes
hospices dont on dispose sont très
insuffisantes
je crois qu'ici ce que nous on veut voir
si c'était avec des exemples de ce qu'on
peut faire je prends d'ailleurs qui
relate aux autres il faut diversifier
les pas plus